okay so I'd like to introduce dr. Shaka
they'll be presenting on mixed effects
random forests let's give him a warm
welcome
thank you thanks everybody for having me
I'll dive right in you know um so uh my
name is sheriff you know I work at
manifold I'm a founder and the CTO there
were AI consulting firm out of the Bay
Area offices in Boston as well mixed
effects random forests actually came up
in some of our client work when he ended
up open sourcing some of the work as a
package and I wanted to kind of talk
about the the package in like why it's
useful when it's useful really so kind
of five sections to my talk but really
before I begin let me ask you guys how
many people have heard of mixed effects
rendered well mixed effects models in
general okay how many people have used
them implemented them okay less less
less how many people never heard of
mixed effects models okay it's good amat
so okay this first part won't be totally
useless so let me talk about what
motivating mixed effects models when is
that useful they are useful for
clustered data as Morpheus is saying
here and I'll tell you what I mean by
clustered in a second but this sort of
data is all around us and it comes up
often in um you know machine learning
modeling problems so I'm gonna use a
classic data set called the Minnesota
radon data set this is the what the data
set looks like is um you have about 900
samples what you have is you have the
log radon level in your home in homes
you have what floor it's on zero
denoting it's in the basement
one denoting is on the first floor and
then in addition you have what county
that sample was taken in and so the idea
is I want to make a model that predicts
what the the radon level in in the
basement or on the first floor will be
so that's what I want to do this added
complexity is that there is this
discounting which is you know could be
useful the problem though is that you
know how do i how do I put that in the
model and the other big thing I'm going
to explain here is that the amount of
samples per County is wildly varying so
some counties have very very few si
apples other counties have many many
more examples and oka County has 52
examples so the question is how do I
make a model to predict the law grade on
and so this is where mixed effects
models are useful and so if you think
about it from first principles there's
really a few ways you can attack this
problem first one is you know what let
me just ignore the fact that there's
County let me build one global model
this is called a complete pooling model
another alternative is on the opposite
end of the spectrum which is you know
what let me just make a single model per
County let me not try to make a global
model another thing you can do is you
could think let me just one hot in code
the cluster the in this case the cluster
is the County let me one hot and code
that and put that in the model and then
what will motivate here is like where
classical mixed effects models is useful
so let's go through each of these in
turn so complete pooling what is what do
I mean by this I mean let me throw all
the data in a single model so in this
case a single linear model and let me
learn you know if it's a zero input or a
one input what will the output be and so
what I'm showing you here is eight
example counties that I've sampled from
from the data set there's actually 84
counties some counties like la Coupole
County has only two samples st. Louis
County has many many many examples what
I have learned I'm showing as this blue
line and so this is a single linear mile
as you can see all the models in all the
counties look the same because I've
learned a single model irrespective of
County this is complete pooling a global
model this is fine but the drawback here
is I can't learn any idiosyncrasies
about that County so perhaps st. Louis
County is in a particular part of the
state that has particularly high uranium
content in the soil so the radon levels
are just like naturally high or
something like that
I can't encode for that in addition as
you can see when I don't have very much
data you know like maybe this is real
maybe this line should be up higher but
since st. Louis County and other
counties that have much more data this
is pulling the model for this county
much lower and so this is the problem
and kind of like the picture that I want
you to have in your mind is that I'm
gonna learn
a single set of parameters irrespective
of cluster no matter what cluster I'm in
so let's look at the alternative now let
me learn a separate model per County so
I'm gonna shard my data so I'm gonna
take learn a linear model for la Coupole
County and you know since there's two
points the line goes through the two
points and so on and so forth as you can
see what's starting to happen is since
I'm sharding the data in places where I
don't have very much data I am like
learning bottles that may be nonsensical
you know I am overfitting I am NOT
learning something that is relevant you
know and it's particularly like even
Ramsey County notice that the radon
level is going up as you go higher on
the first floor versus the basement
which is typically that that is usually
not the case there is a very strong
prior that radon levels are higher in
the basement so that's the problem with
doing no pooling so when you shard the
data and you learn an independent
parameter per cluster the models can
become very very noisy so both have
their drawbacks now there's this
alternative thing I can think of doing
is lemme one-hot encode the cluster so
in this problem 84 element one hunting
coating vector technically 83 and then I
put it into the model and and and see
what happens the problem with this say
you use a tree based model like a random
forest or a gradient boosted tree if you
have high cardinality categorical
variables the tree will get lost and you
know that you can read some some good
references about that but essentially
because of the way the splitting works
in the tree the the the it just gets
lost when you like make really really um
long one-hot encoding vectors and so
there's drawbacks there and in addition
even if you could want hot encoded it
doesn't scale you know even um in the
best case in packages like h2o and R
which do this appropriately but by the
way scikit-learn does not other than a
binary a categorical variable
scikit-learn
can't take in high cardinality
categorical variables directly it
doesn't actually do the random for it's
splitting appropriately but even
packages that do you can only do it
about to about 50 before computationally
it becomes infeasible
it grows exponentially that's why the
the splitting decision so drawbacks to
that as well this is where classical
mixed effects came from so this really
motivates it so what I really want to do
is I would love to have the ability to
learn an idiosyncratic model per cluster
per County but I want to somehow
regularize that across all the county so
I want to use all the data but allow
little bit like twiddles for each of the
separate counties and this is what the
classical mixed effects modeling does
the way you know I'm not gonna get into
the hardcore math about it but what's
happening actually is that you can learn
an independent parameter per County per
cluster but they are regularized using
some prior that has learned across all
of the counties and so the global thing
comes in as these things are called
hyper priors and so these parameters
must be drawn from a Gaussian
distributions that has mean mu standard
deviation Sigma and therefore as you can
see what happens now is that this thing
since there's only two data points I'm
much closer to the average model this
this one over here and this one over
here since I have so many data points
I'm learning an idiosyncratic mean and
sorry an intercept and a slope and so
this kind of generalizes in a much
better way and this is the linear
nonlinear mixed effects modeling this is
what it's all about and this is very
very powerful technique and can be used
on more problems than you think if you
think about this is like clustering by
County if you think of educational data
you cluster naturally by student by
teacher by school by school system
healthcare data clusters often you know
by patient by attending physician by
hospital system there's a lot of
different ways you can cluster and you
can hierarchically cluster this you know
so another name for mixed effects
modeling is called hierarchical Bayesian
clustering so okay great there's still
drawbacks the biggest drawback of
classical mixed effects modeling is that
you have to specify the functional form
of your model and so I call this you got
to know the physics of your model so
whether it be
linear or something nonlinear so this is
some it's a functional form for I think
chemical dynamics you know there's learn
about parameters but I've had to specify
the functional form because I understand
the physics of the problem and you know
this is great but the beauty of modern
machine learning you know random forest
grading boosting trees deep learning is
that I don't have to specify the
functional form and the algorithm itself
is a universal function approximator and
can learn some weird nonlinearities by
itself so I would love to have the best
of both worlds that's where the mixed
effects random forest fits in it is a
model where I can have I can learn a
nonlinear part and right now the way it
stands algorithm has a linear correction
to the nonlinear part that is modeling
the mixed effects the the the random
effects part of it you know to use some
of the terminology from this literature
and so I'll get into how this all works
but this is really to just motivate it
so how does it work
first some history you know this
algorithm I'm not gonna take credit for
coming up with this this actually came
out about HEC Montreal the Statistics
Department their professor aalam and
professor LaRoque you know wrote like a
series of papers in 2014-2015 about this
technique we you know found it wanted to
implement it on some of our client
projects did it and then eventually got
permission from our clients and to
open-source this as a package and so
really our contribution we wrote this
open source MuRF Python package and
actually what was nice those we got a
lot of help from professor alum and
LaRoque we reached out to them they you
know we're very forthcoming shared
they're you know like kind of rough our
code you know helped us debug the
algorithms so just a little life lesson
the Python community this the machine
learning sass committee everybody is
very very open and like wants to share
so when in doubt reach out people will
help it's great so let me talk about the
model a little bit so what we're gonna
do in the mixed effects random forest is
I want to model my response variable Y
as a as a random forest F
that has to be learned which is a
function of my features in addition for
each cluster so I is the cluster index
so in kind of the Minnesota example is
the county for each cluster I'm gonna
have a linear correction and Z is
another feature vector and so
terminology here this is called the
fixed effects covariance these are
called the random effects covariance
this is terminology from the mixed
effects modeling world or what we want
to do now is um we want to learn F bi
and then the hyper priors you know Sigma
bi and Sigma II from the data I'm not
gonna get into the details of how this
is done cuz hopefully this all magically
hidden away from you by the by the
Python package but long story short
story is the way you train this is using
a class of algorithms called expectation
maximization algorithms it's essentially
a form of iterative optimization I fix F
and then train for B and then I fix B
and train F and back and forth and back
and forth in fact there's three steps I
I fix B and I train F I fix after then I
train B and then I estimate Sigma B and
Sigma II from the data there's a lot of
math under the hood that looks scary and
hard but in fact if you kind of you know
D focus your eyes a little bit the math
actually ends up looking a lot like the
common filter because that's actually
what's happening it's very related it's
um you know it's it's Gaussian it's like
I'm doing cool stuff with covariances
and inverses and stuff like that you
know funny story also from implementing
this package this was from the paper we
implemented it double-checked it and
it's just like was always diverging the
iterations would just diverge and
diverge and I was like this is when I
reached out to Professor a'lamin LaRoque
I was like what is going on and then I
was actually comparing it against the
Kalman filter math I was like I think
there's an inverse missing here and then
when I got there code I saw low and
behold there was an inverse the
published paper actually had an error in
it and that when I worked with them
they're like oh yeah yeah that should be
an inverse I was like okay thank you so
like it was like a good Saturday check
but you know if you go detailed enough
you can find errors in published papers
but um anyways not gonna go into the
details too much but what happens at
prediction time so now I have an F I
have a B ah I have a set of B eyes and I
have the Sigma B is at prediction times
there's in fact actually two different
types of predictions like two classes of
predictions
there's prediction for what are called
known clusters so these are clusters
that I saw in the training data for
those I pass X through the random forest
I take Z and I multiply by bi and I get
my Y hat but there could be what are
called new clusters so for example in
the Minnesota set C some counties I just
had no training data for I still want to
make a prediction for that data in that
case I just use the random forest part I
don't apply the linear correction so it
supports both cases and I'll show you
some examples of that in a second so how
do I use it
and so this is like hopefully this is
the magic where you know you can just
use the open source package we have a
very permissive MIT license on it it's
on pi pi you can just pip install murph
there's actually an associated docker
image now so if you want to just set up
the requirements that way there's a you
know the pip has the requirements as
well but the way we've written it is to
have a scikit-learn interface as much as
possible
you know you instantiate an estimator by
specifying there's two hyper parameters
that you have to specify the number of
estimators and the number of IEM
iterations to run run and then you just
call dot fit on that with them you you
have your training data both in X and in
Z and then you have a array of um
cluster labels like what cluster did
that sample come from and then of course
the response variable and you should see
something like this coming out which is
uh the the yam iterations running when
you um and I'll get into what these Z's
look like in a second what X looks like
and there's different ways of doing it
but at a high level this is what it
looks like as much as possible adhering
to the scikit-learn interface what when
you do train it when you do fit it you
can go back
and there's a bunch of instance
variables that are stored in the Murph
object that you can look at so for
example one of the things we look at for
for training is the what's called the
generalized log likelihood so this is
like showing the algorithm converging as
you can see the these are the different
be eyes for the different cluster so in
this case I'm showing the B is for seven
different clusters and as you can see
you know they're it's converging
eventually to some value for the
different clusters the Sigma II hat is
converging the Sigma B is converging you
know after running this for a hundred
iterations if I look at the different
B's where it converged to and I do a
histogram I see something that looks you
know Gaussian ish and so this is this is
all showing that like the algorithm
converged to a same spot I'm getting
some Sigma B and you can see and you can
kind of match it up against this these
are the B eyes that come out so this is
what training looks like on the other
side when I go out to predict it it's
pretty simple I just do dot predict and
then I pass in X Z and what cluster it
came from the package under the hood
takes care of whether it came from a
known cluster or a new cluster you as a
user don't have to specify that
internally it's holding what cluster IDs
it has seen if it's seen it it will do
the correction if it hasn't seen it
it'll just use the default random forest
prediction so how does it do so the what
I'm gonna show you now again we're not
we don't need to get into the
nitty-gritty details of this but this is
actually from the paper as well we have
implemented this as well I'm gonna show
you some results on synthetic data so
long story short this is the generative
model for the synthetic data we actually
have them in the open source package the
generator as a as an object that you can
play with what comes out is it's it's
pretty easy there's a response variable
Y this will be regression it is a
function of three variables X 0 through
x2
these are it's nonlinear function of
those things so as you can see they're
squares and you know ray lose and you
know logs and absolute values in
addition there is a random effect a
random bias that is added per cluster so
this is the generative model for the
data and and the goal is I want to make
a model that predicts Y as best as
possible you know and so this is what
the data looks like the experiment that
I'm gonna show you the results for I'm
gonna have 500 training samples
distributed across a hundred different
clusters very imbalanced clusters 20 of
those clusters only have one sample in
them another 20 have three and then so
on and so forth so there's different
sized clusters I'm going to test it on
actually 9,500 samples 5000 of which are
from brand-new clusters that the
algorithm has never seen also of
different sizes 4500 samples are from
the same 100 known clusters and I have
again like different amounts of data in
each of those clusters that I want to
predict so this is kind of the problem
set up what I'm going to show you is
what I call the like just the percentage
gain that the Murph has in mean squared
error over the algorithm that I'm gonna
compare it to and then I've a verge it
over ten runs one more thing before I
show you the results there's two
important knobs to this simulation one
is called the P tab which is I think
called
the I forget what the P stands for but
it's like the total it's the total
variance that is predictable
so it's essentially comes down to how
model able is the problem how much
unmodeled about nose is there how much
you know exogenous noise is there in the
system so the so the it's essentially
snr so the the more snr in the system
there is the better a model can model
this the lower the snr no model can do
well it's just random Gaussian noise
you know this this last term II is
higher and higher so that is P tab and
so that that can vary between zero all
the way to to 100 and then the other
term is what I'm it's called the random
effects variability and so this is
really getting at how much of that total
model of all variants is in the random
effects term is in the BI versus in the
versus in the fixed effects part of it
and so that again is a number between 0
and 100 the higher that is the more
random effect there is in the system the
smaller it is the less random effect
there is in the system so here's the
results so this is a lot to parse I'll
walk through it together so what I'm
showing here is two plots one is showing
it for the known clusters and one is
showing it for the new clusters what I'm
plotting here on the y-axis is the gain
that Murph had over the compared
algorithm and then the blue curves are
for when the P tab is 90 so it's very
very high SNR it's very very model able
this red curves are for PT equals 60 so
there's much more unmodeled noise in the
system so let's see what this means
let's look at this point right here the
other squares refer to I'm comparing
Murph versus a global random forest and
the triangles I'm comparing Murph versus
a random forest where I have one hot
encoded the 100 clusters so what is what
is let's look at this point right here
which is the best point so I'm
definitely going to show you that it's
what I'm seeing here is that in a random
comparing Murph to a random forest on
the test data I see almost a 70 percent
gain in performance when the P Rev is 50
which is you know like there's there's a
pretty strong random effects component
to this and you know the the P tab is 90
so there's you know there's a high SNR
there's a lot of model ability the game
isn't as high when I do the random for
is one hot encoding but still you know
like it's like 55% so as you can see if
you thought that one hot encoding was
going to do well it's not the random
Morris gets lost the mixed effects is a
much better way to incorporate this
cluster specific information and same
thing here the effect is less if the P
tab is lower because they're just like
less model able like there's leather
there's more noise in the system there's
just less model able so no matter what
you're not gonna get as good results it
kind of is like that it's the normalizer
and as the random effect increases you
get more gain for Murph so this is
interesting this is for known clusters
on the right I'm showing it for new
clusters and as you can see this doesn't
look great but that's like I never
expected Murph to do well here I've
never seen data from these clusters so
what's important here is did I cause no
harm and so that seems to be the case
I'm like right hovering right around
zero so you know for data from clusters
that I have never seen I'm not hurting
it I'm doing just as well as if I
trained a global model so that's kind of
the takeaway here and you know there's
there's some noise here I've only run it
for a hundred runs I should have run it
for ten thousand a hundred thousand runs
but I think asymptotically this should
converge to zero so this is kind of like
did this is where mirth is useful and so
I can't show the client results because
of nd8 things but we've actually used
this on a number of client projects one
in the energy space one in the
healthcare space learning idiosyncratic
models for you know patients and for
particular on buildings in addition
we've actually since we've open sourced
it I think we've open source of robot
maybe almost a year now but like yeah
like let's say like 10 months something
like that we've actually had a lot of
collaborations people emailing us to
collaborate himself there's a sleep
study out of Harvard and MRI imaging
study out of UCSF that have used this
package to do the model modeling and
another thing that we're starting to
work on just to kind of showcase it on
some real data the paper has it on this
particular movie dataset how it has
really good benefits I'm actually I
started doing this yesterday night not
the best time to crack open a new
dataset but I did it on the rossmann
Kaggle dataset
which is a data set where I'm trying to
predict the sales of different stores
and here the cluster is the different
store but I want to learn you know like
I want to learn both a global global
model across all stores in addition to
idiosyncratic things per store and so
there it seems to be on like a
preliminary kind of run it seems to be
doing like about thirty percent better
if I do Murph and and I just use morph
with a very very simple random effects
covariant I'm only allowing the bias to
be different per cluster in more
complicated formulations I could put in
other features in in the random effect
as well so definitely showing a lot of
promise on this data set so yeah if you
guys are interested there's a bunch of
jupiter notebooks checked in to the repo
you know like you could show you how to
use it and look at different things in
it the Minnesota dataset is there you
know how to do you know running the
synthetic data and seeing those Murph
game plots all of that is checked in
open sourced you can take a look at it
and really this is now like the part
where I'm I wanna hopefully you guys
have like know like about a little bit
about mixed effects random forests and
where it can be useful and you know
please if you have a problem please use
it if you can share with the community
please like share your results share the
data set if you can and we'd love to
hear about it the main thing though is
that there is a lot of work still to be
done here you know there's a lot of open
github issues there's a lot of
extensions that we want to do we wanna
what's nice about Murph it's actually
the random forest part the mixed effects
random forest part it's actually um it's
actually a misnomer because this general
principle works with any nonlinear
function so we could do mixed effects
gradient boosting we could do mixed
effects deep learning all of that is
actually possible and so we want to do
some extensions around that right now it
only works for a regression there is a
natural extension to make it work for
classification problems I want to make
it more like PI torch and chaos where
you can pass in a validation set so it
automatically figuring about how many
iterations to run it for because the
number of iterations if you run it for
too long you could pretend
overfit so I there's a lot of work to be
done there there's some newer validation
strategies that I want to implement so
this is stuff that we've done for some
of our clients but nested cross
validation and mixed effects nested
cross validation or some kind of unique
validation strategies that we can
leverage for this type of clustered data
in addition I think there's some
interesting novel research to be done
for doing for making that mixed effect
nonlinear and so a lot of work to be
done and so really you know like I want
to put this out to the community if you
find this useful if you want to pick one
of those github issues if you want to
work on some of these oh please reach
out you know and give us a pull request
well like we don't we'll merge it in
there you know we I'm the CTO of
manifold and we have other people
working on it right now but it's we're
very busy and so it's hard to find time
other than if it's you know unpaid
engagements to develop this so yeah
that's hopefully you've learned a little
bit about mixed effects modeling and
when it can be useful and mixed effects
random for us thank you so much for
having me
and yeah open for any and all questions
I'm curious how you set the initial
conditions initial values for both the
non linear portion and the linear mixed
effects part and whether the algorithm
as a whole is robust to randomized
versus homogeneous initial values yeah
that's a good question I I haven't
specifically explored that in detail
I picked what the what the paper did
which is just be eyes are all set to
zero and then the the random forest is
the first thing that's that's trained so
that there's no initial conditions for
the random forest and so that that's how
it's done right now so you know I I
could imagine that that could be an
issue but so far so good on most
problems it seems pretty well-behaved
that being said just to add a little bit
to your question this can still diverge
there are configurations they did a
particular if you don't have very much
data that this this algorithm could
diverge and perhaps in those scenarios
maybe initial conditions could matter
but if you have enough data it seems
like pretty robust to not diverging
hello so it seems like the clusters were
already inherit in the data set
have you had any success with BOM maybe
doing us unsupervised clustering and
having those part be part of the input
or the the random effect how you seen
any success of that you know I
personally we have not run it that way
that's actually a fantastic idea like
you know do segmentation or clustering
beforehand and pass that in as a cluster
most of the problems that we've worked
on there's a natural clustering and the
data is known so for example in this
energy problem I was trying to model
they're kind of the thermal model of
buildings and I have which building it's
from I have historical data from
buildings for the for the healthcare
that I have you know I know which
patient it is so it was already in the
data but that's actually a really
interesting idea that you have there III
could see that that having promised
maybe in the back first
this was really cool I had a question
about the example that you gave are
actually a question about random forests
about the example you gave where you've
got sort of like a student level cluster
and then you've got maybe a teacher
level cluster so which one was it sorry
you were you're giving me example where
you might have clusters at different
levels or you might have like a feature
that's high cardinality and then another
feature which is you know superset of
that that's locality and that's
something I've never really understood
about random forests so I want to hear
if you had any thoughts like why would
the rainforest ever pick the low
cardinality feature it seems like it
doesn't have any penalty for just going
straight for the highest cardinality
feature there is any thoughts on that
yeah I mean I think and this is I'm not
an expert on this but like the intuition
that I have from some of the some of the
literature out there why does the random
forests get lost because it's trying to
split maximizing like Gini impurity or
you know you know MSE Delta per stage
and when you have the high cardinality
one hot encoded vector it's like no
split on those like passes muster right
and really like the right way to split
high cardinality variables is you look
at power sets like you're like okay 1 3
7 vs 2 & 5 is that the right split to
have and that's the right way to do it
but like scikit-learn doesn't do that
right and so you won hot in code and
then it often never splits on those 100
coded variables because no no given 1
passes muster and so that that's why the
random forests quote-unquote won't split
on the high cardinality variables and so
oftentimes yet people do kind of
bucketing of those high cardinality
variables I think the argument here is
that using a more using an approach like
mixed effects modeling that is much more
naturally in tune with this clustering
could be better there was a question up
here as well
how does the the algorithm handle nesic
clusters clusters nested I you know I
don't think it handles it right now as
it is I I have to again I think this is
probably a question for the professors
at HEC Montreal I I think it could be
extended to do so I think that that's
natural I think essentially in that big
iteration cycle you would have
additional iterations right and in the
training stage
that being said maybe there's some I
know there's like the idea of crossed
clusters and non crossed clusters so I
think there's some care that needs to be
taken but I don't I don't foresee that
like being a blocker
I think this eeehm framework can handle
that as it stands it probably doesn't
but if you want to make a pull request
you should there's other the question up
here at this table as well I think you
said answer that when you mentioned the
example of the number of buildings that
you code it is random variable but in
practice what was the carnality the
maximum cardinality of the random
variable of what in something a client
project or in practice how many how many
levels of that categorical variables
have you seen where it still worked okay
I mean some of those things had
thousands of categories like thousands
of clusters and it just I mean this is
the beauty of it like that's like 100
coding is totally not going to work with
a thousand different clusters this is
particularly on the healthcare data I'm
talking about we had thousands of
patients in this in this particular
thing that we're trying to model but
this thing worked you know it's some it
gets slower and slower as that scales
out but I think again another extension
that can be made is like it is some
things are parallelizable here that are
not paralyzed
that that could happen as well but yeah
I think you would probably break the the
single single computer compute first
before algorithmically failing
the question here no oh cool
so how scalable is this like going back
to the previous question like do you see
maybe an extension for spark in the
future do you see that coming yeah I
mean I I think so I mean like I mean I
don't I don't think there's anything
intrinsically blocking that other than
you know people's time in the developer
communities time so I can definitely
happen right now I mean I think again
our contribution was there wasn't even
an open-source implementation it was
just in a paper so we made the Python
package I think I think this is step one
but you know I can imagine you know like
making the spark connectors desk and all
sorts of stuff that could happen yeah
have you come compare the results with
something like cat boost yes yes I think
like oh like the that's does another
thing we've done as well yeah like at
moose light GBM XD boost same same
issues like if you even cap boost fails
when you have like a really really high
cardinality categorical variables you
know though it does more intrinsically
deal with it it does it doesn't it
doesn't scale on it fundamentally it's
an exponential growth of the power sets
you have to look at
thanks guys let's thank dr. day one
[Applause]